entering his fifth season in the
National Football League and man did
that season start off with a huge Sunday
seven catches for a buck forty seven and
one score as the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
went into the Superdome and came up with
a huge eight-point win and Mike Evans
kind enough to call into the show a
couple of days afterwards how are you
Mike Evans I'm doing good rich you
always always where if I found you
behind a wheel of a car it sounds like
right yes yes sir what is the general
mood around the team right now we take a
little time to enjoy the win and then
you know when Wednesday comes around
with uh we'll focus on our next opponent
but uh everyone's pretty happy with the
historic season what do you take out of
the women what do I take out of it yeah
yeah we can we can be what we want to be
and that's a great team we had a really
good training camp in pre-season worked
real hard for this good start and then
the port's next week do you feel you're
overlooked Mike Evans in that division
that's the general sense I guess but we
don't really care about what people
think on the outside they still have to
play you know step about their plate I
mean people can't just predict things
and then they supposed to happen that
way every single time that's why we play
the game to see what the outcome will be
so I mean we don't care for overlooked
tonight I mean I guess we are but when
you say that you don't care what people
think about you from the outside does
that mean you don't care what I think
Mike cuz I take things personally just
so you know
well you man you got history so we're
cool so okay I care what you say a
little bit and that's some bad or some
bad I don't care
least you're honest about that so look
I'll tell you what what folks are saying
and I'm one of them that the way
Fitzpatrick is performing in week one
that if he continues in that way that it
should be his job even when Jameis gets
back what do you say to that
you know what i'ma say that that's not
my business that that's on the coach
okay my job to go out there and get
opening and cash back from whoever stole
it and that's what I'm we continue to do
so what did he what was he able to do
Sunday Mike that it was we haven't seen
the offense looked like this in many
ways is essentially what I'm saying I
mean they played they played a lot of
man coverage we have a lot of women on
this team no unprotected will and rich
dude what he's capable of doing made big
plays ran the ball when he needed to and
he just was he executed perfectly now I
know if Mike Evans Buccaneers receiver
here on the Rich Eisen show I understand
that you are that it's a management
decision in that regard so let me get
into whatever you might be able to tell
me are you in contact with Jameis have
you spoken with him recently yeah he
congratulated us on the game and that's
always keep it going
I know he said he'll see her soon so so
what what okay
so then tell me about him then tell me
what I need to know about Jameis Winston
that maybe I don't know Mike I don't
tell you just what type of person he is
if he's if he's ready like he's awesome
he was awesome this camp under the
circumstances he was he still having fun
he look that's not seen him this
preseason so not means I'm excited to
see what he's gonna do when he gets back
all right so let me put a finer point on
it the fact that he might not get it
still that he says I understand what a
role of a leader is in the community and
I deserve another chance do you think he
gets it do you think my Kevin said he
gets it I'm not sure I don't see why not
I mean he's young quarterback who took
him first overall and he's a really good
player so pitches really good as well as
well as a brian Griffin our quarterback
room is deep
and they've been they've been having a
really good you know starts disease and
so I mean we'll just see I don't know I
don't know which way they're gonna go
but we'll see yeah but it's certainly
what started off spectacularly well
again one and oh right now forty eight
to forty at some point you're gonna turn
your attention to the Philadelphia
Eagles coming up did you watch the
season opener Mike okay my wife you
watch the shows and stuff but flip
through every now and again I saw a
couple of coal players of the game okay
and what what shows are you watching
with your wife
what's the Mike Holly watched we watch a
lot but our favorites right now are
power that just ended Ozark thanks babe
and I love Jason Bateman and watching
secure among other shows what's on the
shows are at the top three right now I
like I watched Ozark season one well I
like Ozark season two yeah I haven't
finished it yet I'm halfway through but
um it's better than the first one I
would say so far I got aims but it's
been really good so far well how are you
how are you balancing this football
you've got a new contract you got two
daughters at home I mean well you know a
lot only what people know about you is
what they see out on the field many
times and what they know about where the
fantasy league I mean how do you balance
this whole thing like Evans at this
point it's easy you know at first it was
a transition but now it's just I have a
routine let's go to work come home chill
with the fam I'm all days been wife
going dater some will take this take the
girl somewhere and then that's pretty
much it recycles going through so you
know it's a transition but uh it's it's
fun though it's fun I like it
no I'm sure it is being a dad and being
a top receiver in the National Football
League
I mean it just looked on on Sunday and
watching this just knowing that there
was some history between you and the
Saints that it had to feel particularly
good coming out with that win would that
be a safe assumption Mike
yes it was last time we played in their
house they got the better of us they
they would look tall that's pretty good
you know it feels good to get a win in
this league they're so hard to come by
but you know just to learn that they're
in the Superdome and it was crazy the
environment was crazy in there and to
get that win on the road it was sweet
any particular pleasure doing against
Lattimore everybody come on come on the
truth no matter who it is you don't know
you don't care that it's against
somebody that you might have had some
history that the coach was barking at
you last year that Vettel went down last
year that you come in and you lay it on
them in the first week of a season and
blow up everybody's survivor pool in the
process you don't take pleasure in now
I'm happy it's a Division opponent one
guy I mean I mean we've had history you
know why she doesn't in the bag and
things like that but you know just
whoever it is scoring touchdowns feel
amazing and uh you know just winning
games in that fashion okay couple more
minutes with you sir while you're out
there on the road have you been in
contact with Manziel what he's what he's
up to these days
yeah we talked here in there a little
bit how's he doing he's doing good for
my estimation he's feeling better
from those of the 82 I haven't seen him
seen him back on the field yet but I
said he's been practicing and I said it
life's been going well for him so I'm
happy for him and never got it okay and
then someone you in contact with him at
all we don't talk like every every week
or anything like that okay fine you know
I'm not a guy that I don't really like
the takes and call people all the time
know unless they they call me but um and
we're all busy busy guys so we're not
gonna hit each other up every every week
okay anything like that with oh we have
we have a good relationship
okay very good and then you and
Fitzpatrick are you guys giving him any
grief because he's got there all these
memes with him on Twitter Instagram the
like he's a sensation all of a sudden
once again Mike you know when we first
got him I just called his magic all the
time because I remember they used to
call them when he was in New York I
believe and you know I still calm it and
then now the world seeing that you know
he's a baller he's he eats so you
believe in Fitzpatrick is what you're
saying
absolutely okay you're believer in Fitz
magic all right Mike Evans good to chat
with you as always now I know why I
don't get texts from you because I don't
I don't hit you up often enough now now
I'll know appreciate your you take care
of Mike Evans that's Mike Evans of the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers fresh off for seven
catches a buck 47 and a score here in
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience